Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
And today we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you Ruffians for joining us today for our 48th episode!
Oh my gosh, I feel like, Moco-chan, I still remember when we were at like the 27th episode.
Right?
And that was already a while.
And that was really exciting.
But now we're at the 48th episode.
Thank you, Ruffians, for sticking with us!
Thank you!
Or maybe some Ruffians who haven't been sticking with us because... Oh, that's okay.
You're brand new, baby!
FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
Fuwa aka FUWAMOCO!
Please explain it, Moco-chan.
I'm sorry.
I will be better next time.
And it's hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start off your day on the right paw.
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag #FWMCMORNING!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
It's Friday!
It's Friday.
It's a silly day, you know?
A silly day before the weekend, right?
That's what Friday is, huh?
Yeah.
It's chill, why are you there, you know?
Well!
Have we had another... Perroccino?
Ruffians, have you been keeping your eyes open for Peron?
I think at least one Ruffian has.
Guys, we have!
De-den!
Oh my goodness!
Petals up there in the sky!
On top of those... things!
Yeah.
Those things.
What are they?
I'm never too sure what they are.
What's he doing up there?
Maybe he just wanted to get a really good view of his surroundings.
Maybe he wanted to be really close to that Fuwawa blue sky!
Why would he care about the Fuwawa blue sky?
It's beautiful.
I guess.
Sure, sure.
Well, whatever the reason, there must have been something good.
Yeah.
So that he wanted to be up there, you know, on that rusty, sort of, rickety structure.
Sabichi.
That was strong, wasn't it?
What did you do?
I think you shouted something.
What would you shout out to all the Ruffians below you, Moco-chan?
Oh, me?
Yeah, you, Moco-chan.
Is there any other Moco-chans out there?
Ruffians, is there any other Moco-chans out there?
Me?
You.
What would you yell to the Ruffians if you were up there?
I wouldn't be up there.
I've never thought about it, because I wouldn't be up there.
I don't know.
BAU BAU!
I guess.
I guess that makes sense.
That's an obvious answer.
Something more interesting.
Catch me.
RuffianS!
CATCH ME!
That's true, and then nothing happens.
Yeah, I wouldn't jump down.
The Ruffians are just in a state of panic.
Okay, I think that's Moco-chan.
Whatever you do, don't fall, Peron!
Well, he does have his wings, so maybe it shouldn't be too much of an issue.
True, but he is a bit dense, though.
Hopefully he's good up there.
No, no, no.
He's got his wings.
Okay, he's got his wings.
BAU BAU!
He's great.
He's an airbag.
If only.
He's dense.
He's a dense bag.
Two bones and all muscle.
Yeah.
Very dense.
But!
Happy news!
Ruffians!
Did you hear?
Did you?
It's happy news.
It's not FUWAMOCO news.
It's not Advent news.
But!
Marin-senchou-senpai is going to be making an appearance on Fuji TV's year-end FNF contest!
Yes, on TV5!
FNF!
Have you heard of FNF?
Coming outside the FNF music program.
Right!
It's so exciting!
She's gonna be the first VTuber ever to be on it.
And it's a huge deal!
It's a big deal!
It's a huge deal!
Yeah, we really like watching FNS Kaio-Sai.
Because you know, you get to see all the hottest musical artists performing live.
All the ones that are so popular during the year, right?
Well, this year it's going to be split apart.
The show's split apart into two days.
It's a TV show.
One day on December 6th, and one day on December 13th.
And Mari Sancho-senpai is going to be on the second day, on the 13th.
She's gonna be performing alongside other artists and idols like AKB48!
Atarashii Gakkou no Leaders.
Gackt.
Sekai no Owari Yuzu.
Momoe Rokobo's dad.
Right!
Even Hello Kitty, too!
Hello Kitty!
Oh my gosh, that's amazing, right?
It's really amazing.
Right?
Really, really amazing.
Yeah!
Hello Kitty!
It's really big.
Let's all be excited, okay?
We can't wait to see what it'll be like.
But you know, for sure, we'll be cheering a bunch for Marine-senchou-senpai.
Let's all do it together, okay?
GANBARIM!
BAU BAU!
That's so cool.
I was so happy when I saw that on Twitter.
It's a big deal!
Why?
BAU BAU!
Also a big deal.
Isn't it a big deal?
Ruffians, something silly is going on.
I'm always a big deal.
You think that's correct, Ruffians?
Something silly is going on.
I don't know, well...
Before we could even really notice it, there has been a lot of Ruffians, and maybe some new Ruffians too, who've been watching Moco-chan's most recently uploaded YouTube show!
Yeah!
Yeah, Moco-chan's most recent show has reached 200,000 views!
Yeah, you know the one where I go BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU!
That one where I go really fast?
Yeah, 200,000 views!
I, for some reason, you seem to really like it!
And I'm really happy!
But it is, it's pretty silly.
It's pretty silly.
But I guess it really resonated with some of you.
Did it hit you in the heart?
But thank you for watching a lot!
I'm happy it hit you in the heart.
How did you come up with this one?
Moco-chan, tell the secrets.
I BAU BAU really fast, and then I thought, well, maybe the Ruffians would like to see my skills.
Yup.
It was simple.
And that's how it was born.
Uh-huh.
Yeah.
It's just me showing off my BAU BAU skills, okay?
Ruffians, what other kinds of shorts would you like to see from us?
Yeah!
You do?
Probably just FUWAMOCO being FUWAMOCO his best, right?
What?
Do you have any ideas?
Sneezing!
Anything cute.
Sneezing.
I can't sneeze like that.
Confusions.
We like that too, but FUWAMOCO's not animated so we need to ask some really talented demon dogs to help out.
FUWAMOCO!
It's time to know if I'm the best BAU BAU-er though.
Dentist appointment!
For some reason I could feel like that would be popular.
Rock Twisters.
Lots of good ideas!
Thank you, Ruffians!
I think maybe we know what you want to see a bit more.
Secretly recorded.
What?
Secretly recorded voice lines.
Actually, I was thinking of doing that, Tomoko-chan.
Hai.
When we were going to bed.
What were you thinking of doing?
It's not unusual, Ruffians, for us to kind of sing or like hum while we're brushing our teeth.
FUWAMOCO-chan, you were brushing your teeth.
You were brushing your teeth while singing ASCII Senpai's Without You.
I thought it sounded funny.
I didn't realize.
Ruffians, what about any FUWAMOCO messages you want solved?
Anything like that?
Like an educational sort?
You can always let us know on Twitter too, okay?
Let us know in the comments too.
Yeah, we'll give it a shot if you let us know, okay?
BAU BAU!
Speaking of Twitter... Ruffians...
We saw that there was some discussion on Twitter about how powerful we are within hololive English.
Did you see that one?
Did you see that?
Didn't make me that happy.
Because you know, we were put in the C-rank category.
Along with Ame-senpai.
Excuse me!
You know, you realize that we are demon guard dogs, right?
We're powerful!
We're not human!
We'll fluff you up!
You know it!
You see these guard dog claws of ours, you know?
You don't see them, right?
That's because you'd be scared if we waved them around all the time.
But they're there.
And we'll use them.
Oh gosh, you know, it hurts if we use them.
It hurts, you know.
So yeah, we're definitely way stronger than Ame-senpai.
We're way stronger than Gura-senpai, Mumei-senpai, and Nerissai.
Yeah, I guess I have no cards today.
Yeah, Nerissai.
You know, we're at least as strong as Bei-senpai.
At least, you know!
Yeah, you know.
Just because we're cute doesn't mean that we won't use violence to protect what's important to us.
But your smile, Ruffians!
You know, we said we'd protect your smile!
Yeah.
And you know,
We wouldn't say that if we didn't have confidence in our skills to be able to protect it when the time comes.
We need to protect it!
You know, when things need to get extra fluffy!
Extra fuzzy!
Extreme violence.
Yeah.
So, just hope that time never comes.
You know, our callers, they're here for a reason.
Looks can be deceiving, okay?
Yeah.
Ruffians, you know, if you think that Advent is weak, you'll be here for a rude awakening, okay?
Got it.
Yeah.
We're guard dogs.
Demon guard dogs.
Got it.
BAU BAU!
You understand now.
Better be scared.
BAU BAU!
Yeah.
BAU BAU.
I think there's another misunderstanding.
Ruffians, I thought we were doing so well last week.
We were!
But this week, I think it's been a little bit rough.
I know.
There might have been another misunderstanding, Ruffians.
But you know, it wasn't really our fault.
Okay?
I know.
We had to use violence in an ugly way the other day.
During Metal Gear Solid.
Yeah... You see... There was some, uh... Very...
Badly trained dogs that were very rude to us.
You know it.
Yeah.
They almost ate us, okay?
They almost ate us.
Yeah.
And so, you know, we might have had to give them a few bonks here and there to show them who's the top dog, right?
Exactly, yeah.
Cuz, you know, we're demon dogs.
Just like we talked about.
We're not dogs.
We're different.
Yeah.
We're strong.
Very, very strong.
So you know,
They should not be biting us like that.
No, they should not.
Yeah, so... That's why we had to give them a little bonk even though, you know, we might have been safe at that point.
It's just, it's just natural, you know.
It's nature's law.
Yeah.
You know, the strong demon guard dog bonks the ballet trained dog.
You know how it goes.
Yeah.
You've heard it before, right?
The strong demon guard dog, boxed about with three dogs.
Extreme headbutt.
Yeah.
Very strong headbutt.
Just like that.
BAU BAU!
It was okay.
As a dachshund, you know, cute, well-behaved animals would get pet.
Good pet.
Bad ones, hard pet.
Hard pet.
Strong pet.
No misunderstanding, okay?
Yeah, it's just the rules of nature, you know?
You try to eat us, get hard pet.
BAU BAU!
Ruffians, you know?
Yesterday we had, uh... Just chatting?
Just chatting!
I remember it's only just chatting.
Did you have fun?
I think the Ruffians have fun.
Ah, well, you know, we did kind of talk about it a little bit, but it was Thanksgiving yesterday in America, right?
Right!
Happy Thanksgiving, Ruffians!
Ruffians in the U.S.?
Whenever you say gobo gobo gobo gobo, it kind of reminds me of Kobo Senpai.
Oh.
Boko boko bokoi.
Gobo gobo gobo gobo.
Oh, now Kobo Senpai has to say it.
Oh.
Wow.
Anyway, Ruffians!
But you know, we hope that you had a very nice time together with your family and your loved ones.
But for FUWAMOCO, it wasn't the same.
It wasn't!
In the Northwest Passage, we have something similar, but... It's kind of hard to translate to...
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU!
But, you know, it happens a bit earlier in the year.
Yeah.
Because, you know, in the Northwest Passage, it gets cold really fast.
So, it's kind of... It's better to come out of our homes earlier to see our families than before it gets too frigid out, you know?
Yeah.
You know, and we share a lot of our favorite foods that are abundant at the time.
And, you know, it's sort of similar to kind of what you have.
Except, you know, this is actually the one time of year that we hunt
Boobs!
You remember, right?
Right!
Boobs.
They're all over the place at this time of year, you know?
You remember that one?
Yeah!
You know, we make sure to cook the boobs properly though, you know?
Otherwise, it could be a little dangerous.
Just like any meat, you know?
You have to cook them properly, okay?
Yeah.
Yeah, but it's a very different taste though.
It's like a more hearty, savory jelly, but maybe it's a very rich taste too.
Rich taste, yeah.
But you know, it's really easy to get full from the thighs.
Yeah, a little boob goes a long way.
You know, it doesn't have to be a big one.
It doesn't, no.
It's really great during these cold times.
Ruffians, what do you think?
What do you think?
Do you think you'd like to try eating boobs, too?
This year, we decided not to spend it with Mama Puppy and Papa Puppy, because you know we're pretty busy, but we're sure there'll be more chances to see them and spend time with them in the future, you know?
You know, but...
Huh?
What's it made out of?
It's made out of boob!
Boob!
Boob is boob!
I thought... You don't remember boobs!
Wait!
I was gonna say, do you know what hamburger's made out of?
What?
How?
Boob is made out of boob.
It's made out of boob!
Steak is made out of steak.
Yeah!
Yeah.
It's the same thing.
Pork, pork.
Boob, boob.
Got it?
Yeah.
It's not difficult, Ruffians.
You gotta use your head.
I hope that you enjoyed learning a little bit more about the FUWAMOCO from Ruffians.
BAU BAU!
It's always a little bit funny kind of sharing about the Northwest passes because it's not very cool.
I don't want it to be misunderstood either.
No, no misunderstanding.
Wow.
Ruffians!
Wow!
In case you didn't know, Ruffians!
Oh my gosh, you didn't know.
Tomorrow!
It's twin day.
Do you remember?
Soi!
We're releasing a brand new song coming!
Cause it's twin day!
It's super exciting, Ruffians!
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU B
But I think maybe some of you might be a bit curious just what song it will be.
Because we haven't talked about it yet.
We haven't told you yet.
It's been a big secret.
Wow, Ruffians.
Maybe we should let you know.
Would you like that?
Maybe we should let you know now!
Yeah!
Wow!
Can we get a drumroll?
Oh, I thought we would just do a drumroll right away.
No.
Let's do it all together tomorrow.
Drumrolls are important.
Okay.
Yeah.
Dikadikadikadikadikadikadikadikadikadikadikadikadikadikadikadikadikadikadikadikadikadikadikadikadikadikadikadikadikadikadikadikadikadikadikadikadikadikadikadikadikadikadikadikadikadikadikadikadikadikadikadikadikadikadikadikadikadikadikadikadikadikadikadikadikadikadikadikadikadikadikadikadikadikadikadikadikadikadikadikadikadikadikadikadikadikadikadikad
We felt it was a very appropriate song for twin day, you know?
Don't you feel that way?
We're really excited to have you listen to it and we hope that you'll join us not only for the premiere but also for the special after party we'll be having right after too.
And also for our collab with Lui-senpai.
Right before.
Be with us for the whole day.
It's twin day after all.
You don't have other twins to spend it with, right?
You don't!
Why you don't?
That would be horrible.
Please look forward to it!
Yes!
BAU BAU!
It's gonna be a very exciting weekend!
But!
You know, before we go to the weekend... We have...
I'm Doggie of the Day!
Today's Doggie of the Day is... Today is Koi!
Koi!
You can't quite see it, but it looks like...
Moco-chan!
We have to prove to Clyde that FUWAMOCO is good for naps too.
Oh.
Right.
You know, we're fluffy and fuzzy.
Yeah.
That means we're very cozy now.
Right, right.
Right.
Got it.
Fluffy and fuzzy.
We're gonna have to prove ourselves.
How's this, Clyde?
BAU BAU.
Maybe like, uh, uh, hypersmart?
Maybe like Korone-senpai?
Huh.
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU!
Oh wow, Clyde is really cute and thankful for all the walks and cozy naps when he gets together with Kedama Korone-senpai.
It's a good season for the cozy naps.
Right, you know.
And especially when you're busy too.
I think he likes being by your side best, but he understands that, you know, you have your important responsibilities to do too.
So, he's not doing those times.
He tries his best not to BAU BAU.
He's best.
Yeah, and be close with his friends.
They're right.
Good doggy.
Yes, very much.
BAU BAU!
Today I went on a walk.
Ruffians are so good for going on walks, even when it's cold.
Even when it's cold, maybe it's a bit dark, maybe it's not the best.
Maybe.
But we have...
De-den!
That's not cold at all.
That looks pretty nice.
This almost looks like a natural Pero Sighting, right?
It does a bit, but... Wow, it's so cool, right?
A pero hole!
What?
True, it kinda looks like a pero hole, but... No!
The question is, is this a cave with cat ears or demon dog ears like us, Moco-chan?
I always see demon dog ears.
Yeah, you know, they're kind of pointy.
I think cat ears are more round, right?
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU
BAU BAU!
Please enjoy the nice warm weather.
And for our Question of the Day, we received a question from you, Ruffians!
Let's see, we have...
FUWAMOCO, I have an important question to ask.
You know that BAU BAU BYOU affects Ruffians in various ways, and a few Ruffians were talking about it the other day, so I wanted to know if you both also get affected by BAU BAU BYOU?
It's a good question.
FUWAMOCO, BAU BAU BYOU?
I think I feel it a bit different than Ruffians.
You know, at the very least, we've been blue and pink for such a long time that those two colors, you know, together, they don't really affect us, you know.
Right, because some Ruffians, if you see blue and pink, you're like, FUWAMOCO!
Right, you know, but I don't think that's quite...
Mane-chan, right?
And you know, so, we kind of easily sacrifice our sleep and other things that are really important to our daily lives to be able to do that, to be able to make sure Mana-chan's smiling and that we can protect your smiles, Ruffians.
Right.
You know, and we've done that.
Repeatedly for the past almost 4 months.
And that's not really a good thing.
But it's been fun though.
It's been fun!
Yeah.
It's probably not the best.
Yeah, so I think that our BAU BAU view is a bit different.
It's a bit different.
Yeah, you know, we always want to be by your side to protect your smile.
But in reality, we do need to give ourselves some downtime too sometimes, you know.
Especially when our bodies are telling us, you need downtime.
Good.
Go.
You know, it's rough sometimes, but we'll find a way to deal with it soon.
Soon.
BAU BAU!
Thank you, Ruffians, for all your submissions, your questions, for sharing your walks with us, and your doggy of the days too.
Please remember if you have any other submissions, use the hashtag #FWMCMORNING!
BAU BAU!
And for our next team, well our next team is going to be over on Biboo's channel because we're having a watch-a-long each other with all of Abyss.
This time it's Biboo's movie pick and we're watching John Wick.
Biboo's pick is John Wick.
I'm not sure what John Wick is.
No.
It's a movie about a person named John Wick.
I think it's gonna be like Cobra.
Cobra?
Cobra was a movie about Cobra.
A person named Cobra, right?
Barbie was, uh, Barbie was named Barbie.
Barbie was named something else, I don't remember.
Barbie and, uh...
So we hope that you'll join us in Advent all over on Biboo's channel to watch it.
Don't forget to get your copy of the movie, okay, Ruffians?
We also have another scene.
It's not on our schedule, but we're going to be doing a super chat reading!
FUWAMOCO!
We'll be there!
Yeah.
Thank you, Ruffians!
Let's have a really fun weekend, okay?
But, what does the weekend have, Moco-chan?
Well, we have... De-den!
Our schedule.
You know that tomorrow is twin day.
It's a big day.
We're gonna be starting off the day with our first collab ever with Ruri-chan-senpai!
Our first collab!
You know she really likes twins.
We're gonna talk all about twins together with her on twin day.
Exactly!
After that, we have our accuracy Ruffians.
If you have any questions, or like ideas of things you'd like us to talk about, like, oh, write about this with twins, then write us your...
Use the hashtag FUWAMOCO.
FUWAMOCO.
Hashtag H-E-L-P-F-W-M-C.
What we think is interesting might be different from what you think is interesting.
That would be very helpful actually.
I would very much like that too.
Please use that, okay?
The FUWAMOCO hashtag is anything you think that could help us, whether it's questions, or you notice FUWAMOCO made a bit of a mistake here, or you're like, oh I have this fun thing that I made up.
Maybe this would help FUWAMOCO.
You know?
So, please.
Please let us know if you have any ideas.
Yeah, you can find the hashtag in our schedule.
Pinpoist too, if you're ever confused.
Thank you, Ruffians!
After that, we have a new song cover releasing, Identity!
And then after that, we'll have an afterparty for Identity as well.
And then on Sunday,
Get ready for some more Yu-Gi-Oh party deluxe together!
You're gonna need to teach us a thing or two, okay?
Got it.
And that's a weekend plan!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for joining us today for this week's last FUWAMOCO Morning!
This week.
Very important.
That's the important part.
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Kudekai.
BAU BAU!
Maitoe.
Crow.
BAU BAU!
Lemuel.
Tompion.
BAU BAU!
Gremlin.
Claws.
BAU BAU!
Grilltons.
Terrible!
BAU BAU!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU!